you know maybe even becomes drawn like  if you imagine  the f1 disappearing the a pawn  disappearing and fabi getting his king  all the way to b4  some of those positions are drawn not  every single one of them but some of  them are draw and they're also all very  tricky to play  so even those which are not a draw are  often  uh you know people people mess them up  and yeah favi design yeah this is  correct yeah look f2 and design  congratulations  it's a very very impressive victory but  finally i think uh you u.s team can be  more happy by really saving this match  yeah it's a it's obviously a an  unbelievable improvement over what it  looked like when fabini stroke h4 and uh  sam had basically a completely lost rook  ending  uh but yeah now now it's two two it's  only one point one match point dropped  obviously they would have preferred to  win today but it's not it's not the end  of the world